the heading is geometry view I pulled
that out of the textbook just like is
quite funny as a title because geology
itself means 0 nor GME geo geo it means
that is he a very good geography geology
it comes from the words I am with
another implication of verses 1 plus so
geo geo of the others like the most
measurements anyway whatever so we're
going to write down to a kind of shape
that the earth is it and that's why
sterile geometry is actually kind of
what we study it's the main thing about
circle geometry it's that a verb is
roughly spherical
not exactly circle they don't know why
it's not exactly special for started to
started yet you know there's mountains
and valleys and all that kind of skin
but also because the earth turns 50
returns ever sir so as you can imagine
if you had a piece of wobbly clay unlike
a potter's wheel right and when you spin
what happens well it actually moves the
Claytor wobbles around so in fact the
earth is a bit flatter at the poles it's
a bit flatter because at the equator it
sort of bulges out but it's close enough
to a sphere that we can still do
spiracle geometry with it it's so
understated I'm going to come back to
this guy quick oh yeah that's right
which is we're going to come to them
okay so what I think about a few
different parts of this sphere when you
think about your three-dimensional but
the part we're getting interested are
all two-dimensional because that's where
geometries are what in time is there so
what I'll reintroduce some words you've
seen before
firstly I want to talk about great
battles great circle do you remember
what great circle is you've got to be
honest here this CR has a set ha let's
put back om
and if you slice across the sphere so
that it goes through the center let me
say that again if you slice across the
sphere so that you go through the center
so for example here that would be a
great circle we call it a great turtle
because it's the biggest possible circle
you can get or the surface of the sphere
it doesn't have to sit across like that
you can cut through the center and one
bunch of different so for example I can
capture it like this like that okay so
long is that discs that cross-section
goes through the center you're getting
the biggest possible circle so we call
that a great circle great however as you
can and if you just like can't really a
difference what you will probably not go
through the center so we put the sensor
on the sodium and that we deliberately
cut elsewhere for instance up here let's
put up in a funny angle like that or
maybe down here these guys here are not
great circles we call their very
original descriptively
small sensor because they're smaller
than the great circles okay so great
circles small circles it just depends on
where you cut the sphere if you cut
through the center you go away if you
let you don't country the center you get
one of these slightly so I've got our
spheres arranged in this way because
there are very important great circles
that we're interested in that a valuable
firm geography and also very important
small circles so we're actually the
start with the small circle if you if
you take the north and south pole each
other's name is color let's go ahead on
this speed narrative let's mark no more
and south Bop from top to bottom you
have an axis now I'm not going to get
too much into the details of how there
are actually multiple antenna which you
could describe the planet and their
multiple poles on which you could
describe attentive
like magnetic north and then there's
true north and all kinds of different
ones I'm just going to describe it
though as if it just has one so I'm just
going to call this guy the axis on which
it's rotating if you cut the sphere so
that you're perpendicular to this axis
if you cut this viateur your
perpendicular in practice you get a
bunch of small circles like this and
they cut across the circle are so they
cut across the sphere so because they
cut across
we call these measurements of latitude
because latitude like a lateral thinking
latitude literally means across now if
we have a look at all of these circles I
can put you're going to be careful
because you start to get lots and lots
of lines by your area if you have a look
at all of these circles you'll notice
none of them touch each other do you see
that it's like a big sandwich we lock
the lock medium wide and big back I
would love the different layers and
numbers are actually intersecting cross
each other so therefore even in up
straight lines we could call them
parallel these ingratitude sort of
circles so therefore these are often
called parallels of latitude okay now
you'll notice the ones that I draw on
all these ones I've drawn you can draw a
whole bunch more these are all small
circles why they all small circles they
don't go through the center however
there is one latitude I'm gonna put it
in a different form
there is one latitude that does hot glue
right as you go special is B okay
now I put him in a different color
because learners the equator is those
also be that have constants right
through the center the equator is
actually a great circle it is the only
latitude the only parallel of latitude
that is a great circle all the rest are
small circles yeah okay so we got great
circle small circles these are the small
circles that we're primarily in there
you control what two other ones for
example this is not a latitude
parallel data to but it is small circle
there are also a great circles that
we're interested in
so remember that access that I told you
that so if we cut perpendicular to the
axis you get latitudes if on the other
hand let's put the access back on is
going to you if on the other hand nor
sound if on the other hand we cut
parallel to the axis as the continues
the way parallel over here if we cut
parallel to the axis which color shall I
use and look at this blue if you don't
get parallels allowed to but you go as
you get these longitudinal lines like
this now I put these guys all over here
because every single one of these
circles is a fresh circle they all pass
through the access they all pass through
they are through the center ok so all
these are great terminals we don't call
the parallels because they're not
parallel they all cut up every single
one cut all the other ones is that point
of parallels we call them you know what
they call well tomando chi is the
category of what we're describing here
but the actual each individual one is
called a meridian of them is like oh
yeah i remember this from some level of
geometry that I didn't orient a lot it
bugs you okay they are just like with
equate up being a really special
important of the latitudes there is one
of the three is that is more important
than all the rest
and that's see the was it goes to the
grillage right also draws in a different
color so we call it
gia businesses and organism we call this
the primary I said before the parallels
of latitude that may make sense
latitudes because they're there all
across
parallels because they are parallel the
word meridian
it means midday meridian which is why a
APL is possibly a t really connected
eighty-eight as in perform why would
these things be called brilliance mid
days so here's what I want you to do how
many chances am I going to camp here I
don't know two heads will do it
I'll see because I want to I want to
make this spin maybe I'll do it with my
face I can tell you so you got me out
son okay you just use your agitating
right and it's up it's shining on the
earth
okay now let's get discern a little bit
we're just railing yeah okay yup son you
Australia okay so right now Australia
directly facing the Sun Australia
directly facing the Sun in other words
the meridian is facing the Sun so what
time is it right now in Australia
summertime indeed it's a it's midday
right with them for really it is facing
the Sun it's midday because the Sun is
directly overhead if you are on the
surface here and you look directly up
then you're going to see where the Sun
is is that exactly and as you can see
right this is what I'm saying
sure there we go no that'll do alright
so at this one here you can see
Australia is facing way down so we're
heading towards sunset right so the Sun
is no longer directly overhead that
Meridian is passed along so the reader
might now is facing Madagascar video
there he is right there
so render marine that Madagascar is on
is facing the Sun what time is it in
Madagascar if the day is the meridian
okay so therefore there we go that's
like meridians are called Marines
because whenever it is facing the Sun
that exactly midday which is not really
moving okay I take it ruins everything
so we'll get to that a bit later on okay
yeah just one I quickly mention of the
Sun directly overhead the most important
of the readings is the primary which
passes through Greenwich
by the way to sit under when we decide
on the Greenwich Mean Time anyway oh I
remember
heh-heh I think it's 1884 from the
environment
[Music]
we already made sure that the equator is
the most important of the pedals of
latitudes and there are actually two
other pedals that are also very
important even up there we call them the
tropics so if you've got space on here
maybe I want to put them in one the
father ones below a pre-shop cancer is
above the Tropic of Cancer and then the
Tropic of Capricorn is below let me make
sure I wrote that right so today we
prepare our yeah I got right um I'll
tell you exactly where the tropics are
other than in this lesson but I just
want to tell you what they are you
memorized it before similarly there are
certain places where it's like okay the
Sun is directly overhead at
such-and-such time okay if we actually
were trying to do this at some scale
obviously inside of supership in my way
and we are actually mostly pretty much
rotating on the taxes now therefore you
can see for example slot like here
really obviously it's not actually going
to be directly facing the Sun does that
make this think about it even at 12
o'clock in the middle of the day there's
no such thing as noon at this point
because no matter where you are around
in your bobbin this guy is always facing
off in a different direction right at
the same by the same logic it's a point
down here and it never ever faces the
Sun this is why we have bicycles yeah
now at a certain point you do get to a
spot where you can directly face the Sun
like you have to go of fair distance
right coming from the South Pole going
on the second you hit that point really
like oh I can see the Sun midday the Sun
is actually over here from the south we
call that the Tropic of Capricorn
that's the spot at which are now at
midday the Sun actually can be overhead
what do you think that means for this
guy it's the same thing but from the top
okay so if you're too far north at
midday the Sun is not actually overhead
but eventually you come down and it's a
quadrant let me find exact spot I think
it's about there there we go
anywhere along that
Circle anywhere along that parallel of
latitude at midday the Sun actually can
be overhead physically possible so
that's what those are